All right, let's look at some of the interesting
posts on the David Pakman show subreddit.
The David Pakman show subreddit is of course
one of the largest independent progressive
media subreddits out there. We now have more
than 17,000 of our viewers and listeners subscribed@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit someone is not pleased with my
predictions. User re-execute says, I love
David and his well thought out opinions, but
I hate how much he says things are happening
exactly how I predicted them. In reality,
he just says what the public consensus is
in these matters are such as Trump getting
acquitted and then since says things are happening
just as you predicted, as if he's behind the
scenes crunching all the numbers. It's pretty
disingenuous from a guy who I think is a truly
honest player in the political talk game.
I don't know. What do you think? Listen, if
this is concerned, trolling, then very well
done. If it's not, sometimes the outcome is
pretty obvious and I still tell you when I
think that's the case.
If the outcome is obvious, why would I come
up with a different prediction if it's likely
to be wrong merely to be unique, and this
actually relates to something I'm going to
talk about on tomorrow's show. We have a real
problem in the sort of a media space, I guess
I would call it with what I call hot take
culture where unless you come up with something
completely one sided black and white and it
has to be something no one else is saying
it's considered either disingenuous or not
interesting or whatever the case may be. I
tell you things as they are, we have a continuing
conversation on this program and when I say
just like I've been telling you what I mean
is I in the audience have been engaged in
a conversation for a while and when I say
this is going down exactly the way we've been
talking about for months, what I'm referencing
is the fact that you and I have been in this
discussion for a long time and things are
happening as we've observed and predicted
them to go.
So listen, if, if this is your biggest gripe
with me, I'm probably doing okay. I think
if it's just concern trolling very, very well
done. Uh, there was a last week I mentioned
that I was again, uh, sort of categorized
as gay on my Wikipedia page, which doesn't
bother me in any way. It's factually untrue.
There would be nothing wrong if, uh, if I
were gay. I just happened not to be. And during
an edit war that started on my Wikipedia page,
a user named Oh babe 69 was able to take a
screenshot of when someone edited the personal
life section of my Wiki page to say, Pacman
resides in Boston. He is in a long distance
relationship with Kyle Kalinsky, host of secular
talk who lives in New York. He also stole
Sam Cedar's intellectual property. So very,
very clever. And that edit did not stick on
my Wikipedia page.
And in fact, this is just to kind of put a
final point on the Wikipedia thing because
of the amount of vandalism on my page. At
one point someone renamed me David Gay Pacman,
like gay was my middle name. It was a complete
edit war. The page has now been protected
where I think only certain users are allowed
to edit it or something like that. It's amazing
what people have time in their lives for.
Lastly from the David Pakman show, sub Reddit
user password goes here, says quote boo dat
judge is David the only one who can pronounce
boot edge edge. You know what's hilarious
about this? I am being both praised and destroyed
for my pronunciation of Pete boot edge edge.
The reason I say Pete boot edge edge, it's
a slight exaggeration, but at the very beginning
of pizza candidacy when nobody knew how to
pronounce his last name, he said, it's like
the word boot followed by the word edge twice,
boot edge, edge, and of course when you say
it in conversation, you might say Buddha judge,
but I am pronouncing it correctly, although
maybe a little bit haltingly and I hear all
sorts of mispronunciations in corporate media.
Yet somehow people are going after me. Um,
I'm not really that angry about it. I'm kind
of half kidding. Join the discussion on the
sub reddit@davidpakman.com slash R E D D I
T more than 17,000 subscribers to the subreddit.
Uh, one of us, uh, an employee of Reddit that
I know about six months ago actually reached
out and said, we love what you're doing with
your subreddit. It's amazing actually the
amount of engagement and people you've got
over there